We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. The boys and I have fixed up a session of dance music for you. And we hope you like it. One, two, three, four, five. This is 99% invisible.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。了解更多信息请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu。我和伙伴们为你准备了一段舞曲，希望你们会喜欢。一，二，三，四，五。这里是 99% Invisible。
I'm Roman Mars. Four, five. Constraints are good. I think, I mean, constraints are healthy. I'm not the only person to make this observation. 3.4.5. Take five notes. 1.2.3.4.5.
我是罗曼·马尔斯。四，五。限制是好的。我觉得，我的意思是，限制是有益的。我不是唯一一个得出这个观察结果的人。3.4.5. 奏出五个音符。1.2.3.4.5。
1.2.3.4.5. My name is Chad Clark and I'm in the band Beauty Pill. Beauty Pill is a band I really like from Washington DC. Their last album, The Unsustainable Lifestyle, was released in 2004. Since then, Chad Clark had a serious illness that nearly killed him. I had a near death experience in 2008. A virus infected his heart. So usually it swells and you die and I didn't die.
1.2.3.4.5. 我叫查德·克拉克，我是 Beauty Pill 乐队的成员。Beauty Pill 是我非常喜欢的来自华盛顿特区的一支乐队。他们的上一张专辑《The Unsustainable Lifestyle》发行于 2004 年。自那以后，查德·克拉克生了一场几乎要了他命的大病。我在 2008 年经历了一次濒死体验。一种病毒感染了他的心脏。所以通常心脏会肿大，然后你就会死，但我没有死。
I don't think it's entirely accurate to boil this down to cause an effect here, but at the same time his practice as a musician changed dramatically as well. And I just kind of became dismayed about putting stuff out. I don't think I was even aware that that was happening to me. If you talked to me like two years ago, I wouldn't know all the stuff that I know now. Clearly I was resisting, actively resisting, putting out a record. And because he was sick and making music but not putting out music, people began to wonder about Chad Clark.
我认为把这简单归结为因果关系并不完全准确，但与此同时，他作为音乐人的创作实践也发生了戏剧性的变化。我开始对发布作品感到灰心。我想我甚至没有意识到这件事正在发生在我身上。如果你在两年前和我谈过，我都不会知道我现在所知道的一切。很明显我在抗拒，积极地抗拒发行唱片。正因为他生病了，虽然在创作音乐却没有发行，人们开始对查德·克拉克产生疑问。
Being perfectionistic or reclusive. Those are the two words that have been repeated to me a few times. There were rumors. The Brian Wilson fantasy that I like, oh he's going crazy, he's in a sandbox somewhere. So that was the problem. And the whole point of what I want to do with music is communication. So I will admit that it was a misguided path. Here in voice is one of which we'll never sing again When this is over
追求完美或者隐居。这是几个经常被提到词。当时有各种传闻。我喜欢的布赖恩·威尔逊式的幻想，哦，他疯了，他躲在某个沙坑里。所以问题就在这里。我想通过音乐做的事情的核心就是沟通。所以我承认那是一条误入歧途的道路。歌词：这里传出的声音，将是我们当这一切结束时绝不再唱的歌
And this looked like the way things were going to be But then Beauty Pill got an intriguing invitation From Artosphere, a new multi-media art space in the D.C. area They had just asked me to come down to see the space and talk about doing something creative with music Very open-ended, very... We just want you to be creative, kind of idea... The best kind of invitation to receive.
这看起来像是事情原本的发展方向。但随后 Beauty Pill 收到了一份诱人的邀请，来自 Artosphere，华盛顿特区的一个全新多媒体艺术空间。他们只是邀请我去看看那个空间，并讨论用音乐做一些有创意的事情。非常开放，非常……我们就希望你有创意，大概就是这种想法……这是能收到的最好的邀请。
And I came down and we walked around the space and we talked about different things that we could do. And the obvious idea is sprang up. He could create ambient looping music to fill the space or some kind of audio installation. But as they were walking around, they came to a room in the space with a very distinctive fenestration. And we looked into this black box theater and there's a window that looks down into the
我去了那里，我们参观了空间，讨论了我们可以做的各种事情。显而易见的想法涌现出来。他可以创作环境循环音乐来填满这个空间，或者某种音频装置。但当他们四处参观时，他们来到了空间里的一个房间，那里有非常独特的窗户设计。我们往这个黑匣子剧场里面看，有一个窗户可以俯瞰到
theater. Distinctive to Chad Clark that is. I had no idea. And the first of all, the black box theater looked really cool to me, but mostly the window was an interesting idea because the window looks down into the space and I'm a huge Beatles fan. idea because the window looks down into the space and I'm a huge Beatles fan and if you just Google Abbey Road Studio 2 and you will see this design, the famous Beatles Studio has a window that looks down, a second floor window that looks down into the space.
剧场内部。这对查德·克拉克来说很独特。我完全不知道。首先，黑匣子剧场对我和说非常酷，但最重要的是这个窗户是个有趣的想法，因为窗户可以俯瞰到这个空间，而我是个超级甲壳虫乐队迷。因为窗户可以俯瞰到空间，而我是个超级甲壳虫乐队迷，如果你谷歌一下“阿比路录音室 2 号”（Abbey Road Studio 2），你就会看到这个设计，这个著名的甲壳虫乐队录音室有一个二楼的窗户，可以俯瞰到里面的空间。
It's angled almost exactly like the window at Artisphere and that excited me. Beauty Pill would record a new album, that now album that no one thought was going to happen, in the Black Box Theater, in front of everyone. Letting people watch us work. All inspired by a window. And there you have it. The closest one could ever hope to get the dancing about architecture.
它的角度几乎和 Artisphere 的窗户一模一样，这让我很兴奋。Beauty Pill 将在黑匣子剧场里，在所有人的注视下，录制一张新专辑——那张原本没有人认为会发生的专辑。让人们看着我们工作。这一切都灵感来源于一窗户。这就是了。这是人们所能想象到的最接近“用舞蹈来诠释建筑”的艺术了。
They called the project the immersive ideal. And immersive ideal would be accessible and visible to everyone, and we would hopefully lose ourselves in the process. Which is where the title comes from. The ideal way to make music, which is to just sort of drop yourself into it and do nothing but that for a period of time. They had two weeks. There's a deadline now.
他们把这个项目称为“沉浸式理想”。而“沉浸式理想”对每个人来说都是平易近人和清晰可见的，我们希望在这一过程中忘我。这就是标题的由来。创作音乐的理想方式，就是把自己投入其中，在一段时间内只做这一件事。他们只有两周时间。现在有了截止日期。
Now I think there's a way you could view the constraints of this project as a form of confinement. But to chat the immersive ideal was not about putting himself in a fishbowl and being forced to perform a task with everyone watching. It was about opening up the walls and inviting people into the process. In the studio, you can lose yourself entirely, and that can be a really narcotic and wonderful thing. But it can be easy to forget that the main purpose of what you're doing is to make a piece of music that is heard by someone else
现在我认为有一种观点，可能会将这个项目的限制视为一种禁锢。但对查德来说，“沉浸式理想”并不是要把自己关在鱼缸里，被迫在众目睽睽之下完成一项任务。它是关于敞开墙壁，邀请人们参与到这个过程中。在录音室里，你可以完全忘我，那可能是一种非常迷幻美妙的感觉。但人们很容易忘记，你所做的事情的主要目的是创作一段能被他人听到的音乐
and that communicates and transmits an idea or a sensation or an emotion to someone else. It's easy to lose sight of that when you're in the antiseptic, closed wall environment of a studio. Working in the open air, you never lose sight of that as an objective, of moving someone else as an objective. Case in point, the theater slash recording studio was set up so people could only observe through the Abbey Road window. Now the reality is we're nice people, and if we saw someone standing at the window for
并且能够将某种想法、感觉或情绪传达和传递给他人。当你身处于录音室那种封闭、无菌的环境中时，很容易忽略这一点。而在露天环境下工作，你永远不会忘记这个目标，即感动他人这个目标。比如，这个剧场兼录音室的设置使得人们只能通过那扇“阿比路”式的窗户进行观察。现实情况是，我们都是好人，如果我们看到有人在窗户旁站了
two or three hours, watching us work, I don't know it just seemed right to invite them down. So what I would do is I would wave them down. I would wave to them at the window and I would say, come on down and we did this quite often. Sometimes the people invited in the recording area would erupt into a pause, which is not something you generally want in a studio recording. This was one of the manifestations where you could tell people were on our side or invested and wanting it to work.
两三个小时，看着我们工作，我不知道，邀请他们进来似乎是一件很对的事。所以我所做的就是向他们挥手。我在窗户旁向他们挥手，然后说，进来吧。我们经常这样做。有时被邀请进录音区域的人会突然爆发出一阵掌声，这通常不是你在录音室录音时想要的。这是一种表现，说明人们站在我们这边，或者投入其中并希望它能成功。
But the other effect was that the crowd began to guide some of the creative process. On the song Stephen and Tuange, Chad Clark came into the room with a vision for the song. My original demo was kind of slow disco, kind of somewhat erotic, somewhat dark, but kind of slow, too slow to dance to. And I thought this was provocative, that you could feel that there was a dance beat, but it was slowed down to the point where you really couldn't dance to it. And the rest of the
但另一个效果是，人群开始引导部分创作过程。在《斯蒂芬和图安吉》（Stephen and Tuange）这首歌中，查德·克拉克带着对这首歌的愿景走进房间。我最初的样曲有点像慢速迪斯科，有点色情，有点黑暗，但有点慢，慢到无法跳舞。我觉得这很具挑衅你可以感受到有舞蹈节拍，但它被放慢到你真的无法随之起舞的程度。而乐队的
band was feeling that it should have a brisker pace and I was pretty adamant on trying to pursue this vision of slow disco. Who hasn't pursued slow disco but when they were recording this song there's something like 12 guests also in the room. And I could feel as the band was trying to honor my vision I could feel that it wasn't working. I could see that the band wasn't on my side and that I was outnumbered by the band, but I could also feel from behind me. I was like, this is only one in this damned room.
其他成员觉得节奏应该更明快一些，而我则非常坚持要追求这种慢速迪斯科的愿景。谁没有追求过慢速迪斯科呢？但当他们在录音这首歌时，房间里还有大约 12 名访客。我能感觉到，当乐队试图实现我的愿景时，我能感觉到这行不通。我能看出乐队并不站在我这边，我在人数上输给了乐队，但我也能从我身后感觉到。当时我想：这该死的房间里怎么只有我一个人。
There's like 18 people in this room, and I'm the only one that thinks this song should be slow. I think I'm probably wrong. You know, like it was like this. I think I'm probably wrong. You know, like it was like this. I think I'm wrong. And I probably let go of my concept that it should be slow. Sooner, I think, than I would have had I not felt the presence of other people in the room who the spell wasn't working on.
这房间里大约有 18 个人，而我是唯一一个认为这首歌应该放慢节奏的人。我想我大概是错的。你知道，就像这样。我想我大概是错的。你知道，就像这样。我想我错了。我想我放弃“这首歌应该变慢”这个概念的时间，比我没有感受到房间里其他人的存在（他们对这个魔咒并没有免疫）时要早得多。
And if we'd been working in a studio, I think I probably would have eventually acquiesced. I do trust the band, but I certainly feel like the social presence of other people helped me realize that my approach wasn't working at all. But that's not to say that inviting the crowd in the room, even the metaphorical crowd, is the right way to create something. It's a paradox, because if Radiohead, when they were making Kid A, had allowed a crowd
如果我们是在录音室里工作，我想我最终可能还是会默许。我确实信任乐队，但我确实觉得其他人的社交存在帮助我意识到我的方法根本行不通。但这并不是说把人群请进房间——甚至是隐喻意义上的这种人群——就是创作某种东西的正确方式。这是一个悖论，因为如果电台司令（Radiohead）在制作《Kid A》时允许人群
in, while they were working, that crowd might have been completely dismayed about everything they were doing. Why are you doing this? You're a guitar or a rock band. Why are you, I liked your last record. It was great. Why don't you just do another one of those? The crowd doesn't always have the vision.
在他们工作时进入，那群人可能会对他们所做的一切感到极其沮丧。你们在干什么？你们是一支吉他乐队，或者摇滚乐队。为什么，我喜欢你们上一张唱片。那太棒了。你们为什么不直接再做一张那样的？大众并不总是拥有这种远见。
So there are times when you have to knowingly push beyond what is socially desired at that point to arrive at a fresh and worthwhile result. So it's complicated. It's not just one way or just the other. You could never design the perfect situation for creating great art. It just doesn't work that way. But sometimes you have to make some rules.
所以有时候你必须明知故犯地突破当时社会所期望的东西，才能得出新鲜且有价值的结果。所以情况很复杂。它不是非黑即白的。你永远无法设计出创作伟大艺术的完美环境。事情从来都不是那样的。但有时你必须制定一些规则。
And sometimes you have to decide that five notes are all it takes. And sometimes the circumstances dictate that disco is supposed to be fast. It's probably all the time, actually, I know that I think about it. Yeah. Sorry, Chad. 99% Invisible was produced this week by me, Roman Mars, with Sam Greenspin, and may possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute
有时你必须决定五个音符就足够了。有时环境决定了迪斯科就该是快节奏的。其实仔细想想，可能一直都是这样。是的。对不起，查德。本周的《99% Invisible》由我罗曼·马尔斯与萨姆·格林斯潘共同制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持，用创意创造不同。这是旧金山当地公共电台 KALW-91.7 的一个项目，得到了旧金山美国建筑师学会
of Architects in San Francisco, in the Center for Architecture and Design. The program is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public at prx.org. To find out more about this program and beauty pill, you really want to find out more about beauty pill. Go to our website it's 99% invisible. If I say no, then I'm gonna take no way to be afraid So I'm not gonna face to get to a shot of it
以及建筑与设计中心的资助。该节目由 PRX（公共广播交换中心）分发，致力于让公共广播更加公开，网址为 prx.org。要了解有关本节目和 Beauty Pill 的更多信息，你绝对会想去了解更多关于 Beauty Pill 的信息。去我们的网站吧，就是 99% Invisible。如果我说不，那么我将不胜惶恐，所以我不会去直面这个镜头
I feel too shy, I'm scared to tell me my sense That I'm telling my heart now makes it so If we can control the end I feel it is I'm sorry to agree with this I'm not to believe that the sound of the sun is amazing Just keep growing in time, so as kids that are standing by You're going to be a good friend I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a man, I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man.
我感到太害羞了，我害怕告诉自己内心的感受，我告诉内心现在一切都变得如此如果我们能控制结局，我感觉这就是……我很抱歉赞同这一点我不相信太阳的声音是神奇的只要在时间中不断成长，就像站在一旁的那些孩子你将会成为一个好朋友我是一个男人，我是一个男人，我是一个男人……
I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. I'm a little bit more of a man. Starris and sauer
我是一个男人，我是一个男人，我是一个男人……Starris 和 sauer
Starris and sauer Starris and sauer Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere,ere, Sincere,ere, Sincere,ere, Sincere,ere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sincere, Sinc I'm going on it again The way we're going is a solution here In your way again you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Starris 和 sauer，真诚，真诚……我又一次踏上这段旅程我们前行的方向在这里找到了解决之道在你的道路上，你……这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。